[MUSIC PLAYING]
LARRY ARNN: This is a joining
of USA Shooting and Hillsdale
College.
The word college
means partnership.
Partnerships always
flourish when
they serve a common purpose.
Hillsdale College was founded
to pursue four things that
form an integrity--
high learning, character,
freedom, and faith.
JAY WALDRON: The partnership
with Hillsdale and USA Shooting
is super exciting.
It's going to be a very
powerful thing for us,
just having a great partner with
like values, like Hillsdale.
KIM RHODE: Shooting was
something that was passed down
generationally in my family.
And it teaches you
a lot of things
that you use in life every
day, like responsibility,
discipline, focus.
And that's really where you
see meld between Hillsdale
and USA Shooting come
together to really teach that
to the youth, to kids,
and to future generations.
These are things that
they'll take with them
for the rest of their lives.
And at the end of
the day, they're
creating a legacy, not
just for the school,
but also for the future
of the shooting sports.
BART SPIETH: Working
with USA Shooting,
we have the opportunity
to introduce more youth
to shooting sports than has
ever happened at any college.
And we have an ability to
do that at a high level.
JAY WALDRON: USA Shooting
brings in the Olympic
Ring, which is a pretty
powerful statement in itself.
It's the best of the best,
the most elite athletes.
BART SPIETH: Being able to
work with youth to give them
that opportunity to
pursue an Olympic path
is a unique thing for a
school and a great thing
for Hillsdale College.
And we hope to see some
Olympic athletes coming out
of Hillsdale College, right
through the Halter Center.
RICH PEWE: For 175
years, Hillsdale College
has been providing the
type of education that
makes possible for [INAUDIBLE].
And one of the pillars of
that education is character.
One of the ways to develop
character, at an early age,
is through shooting sports.
LARRY ARNN:
Hillsdale College, it
has been an academic,
informed voice
to keep the Declaration
of Independence
and the Constitution
of the United States
in their sovereign place
because it's in our bones.
The Olympics are great.
Shooting is important.
It should be cultivated,
and the responsibility
that goes with it.
There's our partnership.
We are proud of it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]